[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zu den nachrichten den sport
hat norbert lammert für sie also von mir
blicken wir auf unsere großen themen
streit ums gas umlage das geld kann auch
in unternehmen fließen die nicht von der
pleite bedroht sind das sorgt für immer
mehr ärger in der koalition
lernen aus 30 jahren rostock
lichtenhagen
bundespräsident steinmeier hat fehler
des staates eingeräumt und von neuer
rassistischer gewalt gewarnt
und auslosung in der königsklasse
die champions league gegner der fünf
deutschen team stehen fest schon anfang
september geht's los
ab oktober soll es die kassenlage geben
aber die kritik daran wächst auch aus
der ampel koalition denn mit den
milliarden sollen eigentlich
energieunternehmen vor der pleite
bewahrt werden es scheint aber klar dass
nicht alle firmen die jetzt ansprüche
auf die gasanlage anmelden das geld
wirklich nötig haben die bundesregierung
gerät in erklärungsnot
jan fritsche berichtete der
bundeskanzler vor einer knappen stunde
beim bürgergespräch in magdeburg hilfe
von draußen begleiten ihn auch hier vor
dem veranstaltungsort hat die afg zu
protesten aufgerufen wird den unmut
vieler menschen wie über steigende
preise für sich vereinnahmen gekommen
sind nach ersten schätzungen wenige
hundert drinnen wendet sich der kanzler
an die die an einem dialog interessiert
sind die zeit in der das leben ist ja
eine der ganz viele bürgerinnen bürger
zu recht sorgen haben die sie umtreiben
und deshalb ist es mir ganz wichtig dass
wir darüber handfest miteinander
sprechen zum beispiel über die
vielkritisierte gas umlage dass auch
konzerne vom geld der gasverbraucher
profitieren könnten die durch andere
sparten milliardengewinne machen sorgt
für zunehmenden koalitionskrach so müsse
geklärt werden dass nicht unternehmen
die jenseits einer insolvenz stehen oder
wirklich gut im saft stehen sogar
gewinne eingefahren haben dass die dann
auch nicht in den genuss von
unterstützungen kommen können das ist
eine fehlkonstruktion das kann so nicht
bleiben
von einer chaos umlage sprich die union
und will die regelung jetzt sogar über
eine abstimmung im bundestag kippen ein
manöver das angesichts einer fehlenden
mehrheit zwar wenig aussichtsreich ist
die regierung aber weiter unter druck
setzen soll die regierung sagt selbst
dass es ein totales durcheinander ist
was sie mit dieser gas umlage
angerichtet haben sie falschen
unternehmen entlastet werden dafür aber
vor allem mittlere und kleine einkommen
belastet werden erste unternehmen wie
rwe und shell haben bereits ihren
verzicht auf erstattung aus der umlage
erklärt wirtschaftsminister haarweg hat
heute auch andere unternehmen dazu
aufgefordert
wir sehen aber natürlich auch wie viele
trittbrettfahrer ist jetzt gibt wir
prüfen noch einmal ob man außer
anfrage ist das nun wirklich nötig nicht
auch noch mal
eine regelung findet die es diesen
unternehmen schwerer macht noch hat der
wirtschaftsminister aber keine lösung
anzubieten und so loader der streit um
die gas umlage weiter
russland will seine armee vergrößern
präsident putin unterschrieb ein
entsprechendes dekret das ab januar eine
aufstockung der streitkräfte um
137.000 auf dann 115 millionen soldaten
vorsieht in der ukraine hat moskau seine
bombenangriffe ausgeweitet und das von
der russischen armee kontrollierte
atomkraftwerks favorit ist nun komplett
vom stromnetz der ukraine abgekoppelt
einer hebestreit es ist ein
atomkraftwerk direkt an der front
untermieter hat sich die situation dort
verschärft rundherum gab es im russisch
besetzten gebiet plötzlich weder strom
noch wasser wenig später dann diese
informationen des ukrainischen
betreibers wir haben zum ersten mal
sapori hier komplett vom netz nehmen
müssen grund sei dass auch die letzte
von vier leitungen aus dem kraftwerk
heraus durch die kämpfe beschädigt
worden sei genug strom für den betrieb
der anlage sei aber vorhanden alle
systeme ließen normal
internationale kontrolleure müssten
jetzt schleunigst eingreifen fordert
kiels bürgermeister vitali klitschko die
kraftwerk war schon im vorjahr
und
wenn ein reaktor explodiert wir mussten
nicht vergessen und das wird dann geht
er viel größer als
einen angriff mit vielen toten hat es im
bett liegen gegeben beim einschlag
mehrerer russischer raketen starben 25
menschen getroffen wurden autos ein
ganzer zug und ein wohnhaus
wir haben es nicht kommen hören
plötzlich gab es eine explosion und
alles fing an zu brennen
russland behauptet der zug habe soldaten
ins kampfgebiet transportiert die eu
verurteilte die attacke als russischen
raketen terror
ganzer stolz hat der ukraine jetzt
weitere militärische unterstützung
versprochen deutschland werde weiter
schwere waffen liefern bekräftigte
scholz bei einem besuch auf dem
truppenübungsplatz putlos bei dem er
auch ein panzer vom typ gepard
besichtigte in putlos werden derzeit
ukrainische soldatinnen und soldaten an
dem flugabwehr panzer ausgebildet
die wirtschaft in deutschland hat sich
im frühjahr unerwartet stabil gezeigt
trotz der folgen des ukraine kriegers
laut statistischem bundesamt stieg das
bruttoinlandsprodukt im vergleich zum
ersten quartal um 0,1 prozent vor allem
weil die menschen nach der in corona
beschränkung wieder mehr konsumierten
und reisten bessere zahlen auch vom
staatshaushalt das defizit ist im ersten
halbjahr deutlich gesunken auf 13
milliarden euro ein hauptgrund dafür
sind hohe einnahmen besonders durch die
unternehmensteuer
kritik an der regierung gibt es beim
thema klimaschutz so hält ein rad von
expertinnen und experten das
sofortprogramm für unzureichend gerade
im verkehr würden nicht genug
treibhausgase eingespart
insgesamt dafür die vorschläge von
minister wissing nicht die gesetzlichen
vorgaben des klimaschutzgesetzes
auch im gebäudebereich für den das bau
und das wirtschaftsministerium zuständig
sind gehe es nicht schnell genug voran
der unabhängige hart soll im auftrag der
regierung die klimaschutz
sofortprogramme bewerten
vor 30 jahren kommt es in rostock
lichtenhagen zu einem rassistischen
pogrom übertage griff ein gewaltbereiter
mob angeführt von rechtsextremisten eine
aufnahmestelle für asylsuchende und ein
wohnheim für vietnamesische
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter an bevor wir
auf das heutige gedenken mit dem
bundespräsidenten schauen blicken wir
zurück auf die angriffe damals nur durch
glück wurde niemand getötet franziska
von tiesenhausen
es ist der höhepunkt einer tagelang
gewalteskalation bis zu 800
rechtsextreme greifen im august 1992 das
sonnenblumenhaus in rostock lichtenhagen
an dort leben seit ddr-zeiten
vertragsarbeiter aus vietnam ist alleine
und mailand quote im haus sind total am
ende wir können das gar nicht begreifen
in den tagen zuvor bewirft ein rechter
mob das asylbewerberheim nebenan mit
steinen skandiert fremdenfeindliche
parolen
unterstützung kommt von tausenden
anwohnern aus dem stadtteil die den
rechten applaudieren und sie anfeuern
die geflüchteten werden evakuiert jetzt
richtet sich die gesamte aggression
gegen die vietnamesen im
sonnenblumenhaus inmitten der
ausschreitungen zieht sich die
überforderte polizei zurück die bewohner
fürchten um ihr leben suchen verzweifelt
einen fluchtweg bei ihnen ist auch
rostocks ausländerbeauftragter
wegzudrücken sein hat es nicht begriffen
schließlich gelingt es den bewohnern
eine feuerschutztür zu öffnen sie retten
sich ins nachbarhaus rostock
lichtenhagen gilt seit dieser nacht als
symbol für fremdenhass
was in rostock geschah ist eine schande
für unser land für diese schande trägt
die politik große mitverantwortung sagte
heute bundespräsident steinmeier bei
einer gedenkveranstaltung vor ort ein
bericht von susanne seidel
mit blumen sind bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier und ministerpräsident
in manuela schwesig nach rostock
lichtenhagen gekommen am
symbolträchtigen sonnenblumenhaus
erinnern sie an die fremdenfeindlichen
ausschreitungen von 1992 steinmeier
spricht vom damaligen versagen des
staates
das ist umso unverzeihlicher weil
zeitgleich alle auf die situation
schauten man konnte sehen was passiert
die zeitungen berichteten schon tage
vorher von anonymen drohungen von
gesprächen mit anwohnern von einer
heißen nacht in der ich zitiere für
ordnung gesorgt werden solle wolfgang
richter war damals als
ausländerbeauftragter mit in dem
brennenden haus auch heute beunruhigen
in demos wie die der querdenker doch die
zivilgesellschaft habe sich zum
positiven verändert ich glaube rost
druck ist da schon auch ein stück stabil
von der zivilgesellschaft gegen diese
institutionelle und ideologisierte
rechte gewalt mehr als 60
aktionsbündnisse bemühen sich in der
hansestadt um die integration
zugewanderter so hat [ __ ] aus gambia
freunde und unterstützer im
internationalen fußball club rostock
gefunden eine große hilfe für den
19-jährigen um anfang 2017 war es schwer
mit mehr gegen rassismus und
männer habe ich meine ausbildung
abgebrochen wegen rassismus
fremdenfeindlichkeit ist ein
deutschlandweites problem so die
integrationsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung es war ja nicht nur
rostock lichtenhagen danach kamen
weitere rassistischer anschläge also wir
müssen da alle gemeinsam mussten die
bundespräsident steinmeier betont
hierbei komme es auf jeden einzelnen an
rostock lichtenhagen vor 30 jahren war
sie auch gesehen haben ein zdf-team
sonnenblumenhaus und hat die
rassistischen ausschreitungen miterlebt
die reportage von damals können sie in
der zdf mediathek sehen unter dem titel
kennzeichen d spezial das pogrom in
rostock lichtenhagen
und wie gross weiterhin die gefahr durch
den rechtsextremismus ist zeigt der mord
am kasseler regierungspräsidenten weiter
lücke im juni 2009 10 der
rechtsextremist stefan ernst wurde wegen
mordes zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt
mit besonderer schwere der schuld ein
mitangeklagter bekam eine
bewährungsstrafe
alle seiten leben aus unterschiedlichen
gründen revision ein aber der
bundesgerichtshof bestätigte heute die
urteile der einzelheiten von christoph
schneider der fokus liegt am vormittag
auf dem staatsschutzsenat des
bundesgerichtshofs im fall lübke werden
sämtliche revisionen verworfen die vom
oberlandesgericht getroffenen
feststellungen beruhen auf einer aus
revisionsrechtlich sicht fehler freien
beweiswürdigung und tragen sowohl die
schuld als auch die freisprüche für die
richterinnen und richter am
oberlandesgericht frankfurt am main
stand fest dass ernst allein anfang juni
2009 10 walter lübke auf der terrasse
seines hauses in nordhessen heimtückisch
erschossen getrieben von rassistischen
und fremdenfeindlichen motiven
neben ernst wurde der mitangeklagte
markus h wegen unerlaubten
waffenbesitzes verurteilt nicht aber
wegen beihilfe zum mord denn es hatten
sich keine beweise dass h neben ernst
ebenfalls am tatort gewesen sein für
familie lübke ist das schwer
nachzuvollziehen weil sie unverändert
davon überzeugt ist dass beide die tat
gemeinsam geplant
vorbereitet und auch verübt haben für
den bundesgerichtshof hingegen sind
sämtliche begründungen des
oberlandesgerichts plausibel und
nachvollziehbar die entscheidung der
richterin und richter hier am
bundesgerichtshof in karlsruhe am
obersten deutschen strafgericht ist
glasklar keine fehler gefunden damit
wird es auch keine erneute
wahrheitssuche im mordfall abgegeben wie
von den hinterbliebenen gefordert der
mordfall lücke ist mit dieser
entscheidung endgültig abgeschlossen
zumindest rechtlich
und wir blicken ins ausland fünf jahre
flucht und immer noch keine perspektive
hunderttausende wohin sein leben ende
völlig überfüllten flüchtlingslagern in
bangladesch
hilfsorganisationen sind alarmiert 20 17
hatte die armee im überwiegend
buddhistischen mia die muslimische
minderheit der rohingya brutal
angegriffen und gräueltaten begangen
mehr als 700.000 euro hin dass mussten
fliehen in den flüchtlingslagern
protestierten tausende für bessere
lebensverhältnisse
seit 2020 läuft vor dem internationalen
gerichtshof ein verfahren wegen
völkermordes
zwischen europa und marokko liegen
gerade mal ein paar kilometer heute
besuchte außenministerin bernburg das
königreich im norden afrikas nach einer
politischen eiszeit wollen beide länder
ihre beziehungen wieder aufleben lassen
anlass des streits die westsahara ein
dünn besiedelte höchsten regionen an der
atlantikküste
die beansprucht marokko seit den 70er
jahren für sich obwohl der frühere
us-präsident die annexion überraschend
anerkannte leben die meisten anderen
staaten nicht anerkennung also kann
einfach über sucht heute für berbalk
andreas kienast
rabatt muss warten eine ministerin aus
deutschland hat vorfahrt so ein bild
unvorstellbar in den vergangenen monaten
so schlecht so frostig waren die
beziehungen dass deutschlands
botschafter keinen termin mehr bekam
keine einladung keinen anruf der
handschlag mit außenminister morita
beendet die krise und schafft die
möglichkeit auch mit marokko wieder über
klimaschutz flüchtlinge aber vor allem
über energie über grünen wasserstoff zu
reden wir als bundesrepublik deutschland
aber auch die europäische union
insgesamt können uns nie wieder abhängig
machen von ländern die unsere werte
nicht teilen das zahlen wir gerade
dieser tage mit einem hohen preis das
marokko ein großes territorium des
wüsten lanz westsahara für sich
beansprucht hat kein staat der welt
anerkannt bis der damalige präsident
trump im namen der usa die annexion
akzeptierte als deutschland daraufhin
eine sitzung des un-sicherheitsrats
einberief tobte marokko und brach die
diplomatischen beziehungen de facto ab
heute lobt außenminister berieten die
ausgewogene haltung der lieben kollegin
lebek kollegin marina warum man hier in
rabat gerade jetzt wieder auf
deutschland zugeht ist nicht ganz klar
zwar hat die neue bundesregierung in ein
paar kleineren formulierungen geschraubt
aber eigentlich hat sich die position
deutschlands überhaupt nicht verändert
warum deutschland auf marokko zugeht ist
kein geheimnis das königreich soll eine
säule der eu energiewende werden
und jetzt kommen wir zur
fußball-champions-league nah bei dir
morgen aber ganz aktuell die gruppen
ausgelost im istanbuler spannende
gruppen komme ich gleich drauf es sind
ja erstmals fünf deutsche mannschaften
in den lostöpfen gewesen neben bayern
den bvb leverkusen in leipzig auch die
eintracht aus frankfurt als europa
league sieger und jetzt schauen wir uns
nur an gegen den die fünf antreten
müssen in der gruppe b trifft leverkusen
auf den fc porto atletico madrid und
club brügge aus belgien ein machbares
programm für die bayern in der gruppe c
treffen die bayern auf den fc barcelona
und damit auf robert lewandowskis neuen
verein inter mailand und der
tschechischen meister viktoria pilsen
die sind auch dabei eine anspruchsvolle
gruppe in der gruppe d trifft eintracht
frankfurt auf tottenham hotspur
sporting lissabon und olympique
marseille
eigentlich ganz gute karten die
eintracht in der gruppe f hat es der rb
leipzig mit dem champions-league-sieger
real madrid zu tun der ukrainische
meister donezk und celtic glasgow starke
gegner für rb ja und in der gruppe g
trifft der bvb auf den englischen
meister manchester city den fc sevilla
und kopenhagen auch eine schwere gruppe
für die dort moderne
zur deutschlandtour nach dem prolog
gestern mit dem einzelzeitfahren heute
die erste von vier etappen knapp 172
kilometer durch thüringen von weimar
nach meiningen sieger der australier
kälin und vier deutsche unter den ersten
zehn letztlich chancenlos romantiker der
letzte von vier ausreißern die die
etappe prägten 13 kilometer vor dem ziel
wird der 20-jährige deutsche vom
heraneilenden feld geschluckt logische
folge die radsportfans im thüringischen
meiningen erleben einen packenden sprint
um den ersten etappensieg wie geschaffen
für keller juden den zweiter von rechts
im roten trikot mit türkisen dem helm
klarer sieg vor dem italiener milan
sowie den deutschen max kanter und felix
probst in position gebracht von seinen
teamgefährten von lotto zu tal darunter
roger kluge nutzt der australier die
entscheidende lücke und
morgen die zweite etappe von mining nach
marburg bei uns zu sehen im sportstudio
live ab 15 uhr 5
die dürre in diesem sommer macht ja
viele probleme aber sie bringt auch so
manch verborgenes wieder ans tageslicht
in einem ausgetrockneten flussbett in
texas sind jetzt schritt für schritt
versteinerte dem spuren aufgetaucht die
meisten sind von einem fleischfresser
namens agro cantos augus der hier vor
rund 120 millionen jahren lebte und
jagte denn damals war hier das ufer
eines meeres an dem viele dinosaurier
unterwegs waren
große fußstapfen beim wetter ändert sich
jetzt was morgen drohen von der nordsee
bis nach bayern heftige gewitter
einzelheiten gleich von katja vorne
fahren das heute schon mal können sie in
diesem abend um 22.15 mit marietta
slomka und morgen begrüßt sie hier an
dieser stelle aber häufig auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die luft wird feuchter von
osten das machte sich heute dadurch
bemerkbar dass sich diese nebelfelder
hier in mecklenburg vorpommern lange
hielten als sie sich auflösten
entwickelten sich schnell quellwolken
für uns interessant ist auch das
wolkenband über frankreich
großbritannien heute nacht gibt es
häufig wolken und hier im osten sind
schon einige schauer oder kurze gewitter
unterwegs an der mosel sinken die
temperaturen bis 20 grad deutlich
frischer wird die nacht an den alpen mit
elf grad und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen im osten dann bei 24
bis 27 grad zwischen hannover und dem
oberrhein wird es dagegen fast überall
noch mal heiß mit 29 bis 32 grad das ist
nämlich genau die region in der es
morgen vormittag noch am meisten sonne
gibt westlich des rheins komm schon
einige schauer an und dann gibt es
dieses band mit regenschauer und
gewitter in ungefähr zwischen der
lüneburger heide und der donau diese
gewitter wachsen sich dann am nachmittag
aus sie ziehen ganz langsam können also
örtlich eng begrenzt viel regen
mitbringen da drohen also
überschwemmungen und am samstag gibt es
noch weitere gewitter vor allen dingen
in der osthälfte dann beruhigt sich das
wetter langsam von westen am montag bei
temperaturen von 20 bis 28 grad guten
abend